on se regarde un produit qui est un
petit peu particulier un peu un petit
peu à part regarder des choses que je
voulais vous montrer c'est le carton
asus n'a fait une petite
personnalisation niveau du carton
regardez ils ont mis un logo greu là ça
ça me plait merci injuste c'est vrai que
dans l'univers des portables et bien il
y en a de tous les formats tous les
côtés à tous les prix pour tout le monde
et puis surtout on voit qu'il ya un
grand changement une grande évolution
qui s'est opérée avec la crise du comité
c'est à dire que panda tous travaillé
chez nous enfin tous quasiment tous
travailler de chez nous en tout cas et
on a eu un gros besoin d'équipements
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu un vrai boom
au niveau de la vente des pc et on se
rend compte qu'on a des besoins de
mobilité on a besoin dans l'extérieur on
a besoin aussi de travailler à
l'intérieur avec un pc et asus ces
listes dommage de devoir avoir plusieurs
appareils pour pouvoir bosser de chez
soi pour pouvoir un à l'extérieur alors
forcément il ya des configurations vous
aurez besoin d'avoir une machine dédiée
à l'intérieur d'une machine pour
l'extérieur parce qu'ils auraient
peut-être des besoins de performance
chez vous ça sera compliqué dans d une
grosse machine bien longs derrière
extérieur mais pour la plupart des gens
qui vont venir faire de la productivité
familiale la productivité
professionnelle word excel de la conf
etc vous n'avez pas forcément besoin
d'une très grosse machine qui va être
contraignante à déplacer d'où l'idée de
venir avec un produit assez atypique
dans la gamme d'asus qui arrivent ici
c'est le vivent au bouc slade 13 oled
on m'a dit tu vas voir expérience ça y
est plutôt cool
alors regardez déjà pas souffre comme ça
ok on enlève les papiers pas perdre de
temps avec ça ça c'est très canon comme
bois round the world vive au bout qui
vont bien un petit autocollant monsieur
ça c'est super sympa un caïd et leurs
possibilités vous avez même des petites
des petites flèches sur le côté à d'être
assez fou le truc une expérience est
superbe est en fait ce sont plusieurs
accessoires vous avez à la fois un
ordinateur écran vous avez à la fois un
clavier vous avez à la fois une petite
cover vous à la fois le asus peine il ya
un côté hyper frais hyper contemporain
hyper jeunes qui vous marque commence à
marcher s'il a regardé la soie it left
right c'est à dire laisser sur le côté
avec trois doigts à droite et à gauche
pour switcher entre les applications
avec cap doit à droite et à gauche pour
changer de bureau cette expérience elle
est allée à ces dingos qu'ici on a quoi
le clavier c'est joli c'est vraiment ce
qui est super sympa j'aime beaucoup
c'est ce produit que ça coince à
dépenser ses flèches ça fait penser à
des alala business france sas et petit
cover qu'on va venir ça c'est ce qu'on
vient poser au dos je pense de la
machine pour pouvoir le mettre en
position stand oneworld slide pis si on
a ici tout en un seul ordinateur on a un
intel pentium sylvain c'est la référence
se donne dans quelques instants j'ai une
petite housse pour venir le balader et
lequel ils durent possibilities explore
morts on a le asus peine 2.0 et oui
parce que j'ai des produits de mobilité
bien il ya des personnes qui vont
vouloir venir pourquoi pas dessiner
grifoni alors attention ici on n'est pas
sur un produit fait pour la créativité
on peut venir dessiner en peut venir
prendre des notes mais ça va pas être un
produit foule créatif on va pas utiliser
une tablette graphique en pas voir le
max de performance c'est vraiment un
produit dédié à la mobilité ce qui donc
il faut vraiment pas se tromper d'usagé
ça lui a coûté un peu agent secret joue
je ferme pour une recharge et ça c'est
sympa j'ai des mines interchangeables
alors si vous regardez on les voit là ce
doit être en 2h pour venir l'enlever
bien vous prenez ça vous gardez vous
jetez pas vous le prenez vous l'a coincé
là et vous tirez et ça vous a retiré
votre mine après pour la ram et c'est
facile vous prenez vous la mettez dedans
vous appuyez votre minet poser ensuite
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça c'est pour
venir poser votre stylet et serrières
d'être je suppose aimanté vous pouvez
sur le côté bon ça c'est malin ça roule
avec votre asus peine vous avez bien
évidemment un petit câble de
rechargement en usb en usb cd on va
retrouver votre bloc de chars 65 watts
et son singe en usb c'est
moi j'ai tout fait ni de configurer tous
fini d'installer j'ai regardé j'ai fait
un tour complet je vous dise que ça
raconte l'histoire vous avez votre
ordinateur qu'on peut être ça commence
en ordinateur tablette est très
surprenante bien vous allez votre
ordinateur mais ça ordinateur et c'est
écrit oddo ici slate pisi donc c'est un
pc alors vous prenez ça regardez c'est
tout prévu c'est bien pensé c'est
totalement inventé et là vous venez
juste bouger votre petit charnière alors
ça franchement c'est pas mal parce que
ça sent quand même la robustesse ça m'a
quand même vachement euros je vais vous
pouvez le poser comme ça vous l'avait
prescrit un peu plus là j'ai en face de
moi je peux utiliser donc en mode
chevalet pour me regarder des films des
séries c'est vraiment le côté visionnage
si je veux le coucher au max m'a regardé
comme sens vois dedans peut venir
l'utiliser pour venir dessiner griffonné
revient à lui mais j'ai mon bouton ici
capteur d'empreintes digitales avec
windows et l'eau ça va plutôt pas mal
j'ai ensuite mon asus pencil 2.0 que je
peux venir utiliser ici pour ouvrir pour
naviguer et donc le truc assez pratique
si vous voulez utiliser un stylet bien
vous l'avez ça c'est pas mal moi je suis
pas un grand utilisateur de stylet mais
je dois reconnaître que c'est quand même
très pratique par moi je le trouve un
petit peu lent vous dire qu'ici on est
sur un pentium silver n 6 milles vous
allez soit 4,64 à moi le plaisir 4x et
vous avez un ssd pcie 128 giga de
stockage on n'est pas dans l'idée de la
créativité on n'a pas un gros stockage
on est vraiment dans l'idée d'avoir une
tablette pour la productivité pour venir
s'amuser pour mieux griffonné dessinée
travailler avec un stylet si on aime
tram avec un stylet mais vous n'allez
pas faire ici du photoshop multicartes
voilà vous oubliez ça complètement vous
le sortez de votre tête pas de vidéo
rien de tout ça du divertissement est
purement du divertissement et un peu de
productivité familiale on va vous parler
de l'écran et vous montrer un peu le
côté technique vous avez en plus ici
votre petit clavier qui vient regarder
au plat ce clip cc aimantait ce qui fait
que vous reposer un peu ça comme ça
derrière et ça vous fait un petit
ordinateur un peu comme on pouvait
retrouver dans l'idée je mets des
grandes ligues mais quand je dis ça
comme la surface pro on pourrait se dire
qu'on peut faire un peu de dimming mais
vraiment du gaming comme on le ferait
sur un smartphone qui avait pas beaucoup
de performance donc pour tout ce qui va
être joué online vous allez pouvoir le
faire très facilement le cloud gaming ça
marchera très très bien dans la mesure
où vous avez une connexion internet
qu'il le permet mais pour tout ce qui va
être installations de jeu ici qui
nécessite un peu de ressources vous
oubliez une fois qu'il est refermé vous
le prenez un plat ça va bouger prenez ça
vous rhabiller correctement vous posez
et là vous avez un petit lattois vous
pouvez bien repartir avec leur c'est
pareil pour votre stylet vous le prenez
vous le mettez là dedans vous posez
votre style et là regardez vous avez la
marque en fait ici en plus il est livré
avec windows 11 natif si vous voulez une
machine qui est native sous windows pour
que vous avez ce qu'il faut instiller la
4me 96 points de pression et surtout il
a un taux d'échantillonnage de 266 hertz
alors moi je dis qu'on parle un peu de
cet écran parce que comme on est si
vraiment sur un produit qui est destiné
au visionnage et bien l'écran et si
c'est pour moi focus qui est extrêmement
important voyez lorsque vous le poser à
plat comme ça il n'est pas hyper stable
il faut vraiment venir penser à retirer
la partie arrière pour qu'il soit
totalement stable et que ça fasse bien
la faire vous pouvez l'utiliser dans un
sens ou dans l'autre comme vous voulez
enfin c'est vraiment cool si vous voulez
l'utiliser pour adé du tic toc ou très
grand format et bien écoutez pourquoi
pas fait comme ça ça fonctionnera donc
ici moi j'ai un grand écran qui me donna
de 13,3 pouces et du format 16/9 à vous
c'est le format pour venir regarder des
films des séries 100% dci p3 jusqu'à 550
nits en termes de luminosité donc c'est
pas forcément l'appareil le plus
ne lorsque vous allez l'emmener à
l'extérieur et qui a beaucoup de lumière
donc si vous vous dites qu'en planète et
vous voulez regarder une petite série au
jardin du luxembourg on ne s'était pas
ça qu'il vous faudra voir vous mettez à
l'abri sous les bois il est deux
divisions certifié pantone hdr et les
certifier lutter contre la lumière bleue
une certification tüv rheinland on a ici
en plus quatre haut parleurs pour
l'expérience audio le haut parleur
fantasmes et on est un peu dans une
expérience médium si vous voulez aller
plus loin vous avez une prise jack et
puisqu'on est dans la connectique
regardez ces scandales vous avez deux
usb cia lecteur carte micro sd 4 haut
parleurs dolby atmos alors regardez j'ai
vous montrer je vais sur netflix mais
j'ai mon application des flics c'est un
truc intéressant si avec 1000 de seconde
zone et parlé dans une précédente vidéo
de windows os vous êtes des applications
catalogue de microsoft il vous avez en
plus des applications android et ça va
s'étoffer donc c'est plutôt intéressant
famille comme ça à faire c'est quand
même un peu médium haute en terme
d'expérience le son est un peu médium
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez quatre haut parleurs qui
vont venir apporter une expérience de
stéréoscopie et sinon bluetooth 5.2 pour
me rappelle un casque sans fil très
facilement et si vous voulez faire de la
conférence parce que ça sent le truc
intéressant vous avez deux webcams je
vous montre et surtout nous avons
technologie de suppression du bruit
ambiant avec intelligence artificielle
qui vous permettra vous devenir
converser avec des amis ans de boulot et
compagnie sans qu'on entende ce qui se
passe autour mais ça va venir analyser
supprimer un peu ce qui est autour de
vous ça c'est plutôt pas mal alors après
je vous le disais vous avez deux petite
webcam une qu'est planqué à l'avant
juste la cdu 5 mégapixels alors autant
j'ai de la reconnaissance du visage et
donc ça me fait le point sur moi voulait
que le petit carré bleu la qualité est
assez sommaire de ce sept caméras là si
vous voulez un truc un petit peu mieux
vous voulez soutien derrière vous avez
une caméra de 13 mégapixels qui sera
meilleur en termes de qualité autant
vous allez pas venir faire une console
comme ça parce que personne vous verrez
autant si vous avez quelque chose à
venir montrer lors d'une conférence vous
le prenez vous allez votre ordinateur
tablette comme ça 2 en 1 380 bref tout
en un un autre truc intéressant je vous
ai pas encore montré ce bloc de charges
nous le dit de bloc de charge 65 ouaki
si vous avez une batterie de 50 watts
heures alice nous annonce ou de recharge
à 60% seulement 39 minutes social ces
pratiques est à peu près 9h30
d'autonomie alors une fois de plus ça va
dépendre de vos usages si vous avez des
usages mixtes pourquoi pas si vous êtes
tout le temps dessus essayer de gratter
dans les performances et l avenir faire
patiner bon ça sera un petit peu moins
c'est une machine qui est silencieuse
parce qu'on n'a pas de ventilateur ici
elle peut légèrement chauffé ainsi vous
la fait beau c'est un petit peu mais
comme vous allez m et bien aux places à
derrière
sentirez pas trop vous la mettez en mode
chevreuil sauce intéressant donc moi ce
que je retiens ce qui m'intéresse ici
est bien c'est que c'est une machine qui
va être polyvalente ça va pas être la
plus performante en pas faire le plus de
choses avec mais surtout au tarif de 499
euros avec votre écran et votre stand
votre chevalet en plastique aimanté si
vous voulez clavier il faut rajouter 100
euros vous arrivez à 599 euros au niveau
du package et si vous voulez le style
est là où c'est vous le voulez ou 8
gigas de ram vous êtes à 699 euros donc
la question à venir se poser ici c'est
quels sont vos besoins quels sont vos
usages est ce que vous voulez une
expérience pc avec de la mobilité une
machine que vous allez emmener partout
avec vous qui va être un combo ou à
pouvoir venir à la maison regarder des
films des séries qui nous permettra
également de travailler sur la petite
productivité familiale et
professionnelle de pouvoir utiliser
office ici tout ce qui va être
expérience google docs très facilement
bien évidemment pas gaming ou du gaming
vraiment pas performant vous mettez un
petit cours du crush ça ira très bien où
quelques petits jeux de lapins crétins
ne va pas aller bien plus loin que ça
donc si vous cherchez une expérience
complète sur une petite productivité
divertissement mais pas particulièrement
gaming et bien vous avez un truc est
vraiment intéressant avec ce niveau book
13 slate oled on peut ici il faut savoir
vous avez du wifi 6 dont le terme de
connexion ça va ça devrait aller si vous
avez besoin de plus de performance vous
avez d'autres produits chez asus il va
falloir payer davantage c'est une
machine qui veulent disponible sur la
configuration à 499 et 599 mifa novembre
soumet les liens en bas par la
description et sur la plus grosse config
avec le 8 gigas de ram à 699 ça va être
mis fin décembre voire début janvier de
l'année prochaine l'expérience globale
mal me satisfait plutôt pas mal faut que
le clavier est plutôt aussi bien réussi
alors ici moi il m'a envoyé un clavier
qwerty mais vous vous aurez un clavier
en azerty soyez rassurés d'une petite
touche pour venir couper mon micro et
venir l'actionner que ça aussi pas mal
un grand trackpad qui est assez
confortable j'aime beaucoup si le design
bref c'est un produit qui sera sec et ip
qui est signée qui me semble et ont
adressé plus un public jeune étudiant
des jeunes travailleurs sur dix jeunes
travailleurs samedi jeunes travailleurs
ça c'est étrange jeunes travailleurs tu
sais pas si je devrais utiliser ce terme
là un petit
18 25 30 ans si vous avez 30 50 pouvez
acheter bien évidemment ça correspond à
vos usages pour moi je trouve pas mal
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas l'idée est
surtout commencé à moins de 500 euros
avec un pc windows
ça ça me paraît plutôt pas mal parce que
vous en pensez en banque quant à nous on
se retrouve très rapidement on va
continuer à parler tech avec des
produits un peu cool des produits
atypiques des produits différents va
parler d' usage on va parler de tutos
appareils de plein de choses donc si
vous n'êtes pas abonné pensez à vous
abonner ses boutons et rouge juste en
dessous vous actionnez la cloche on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer par
les teg vous embrasse des bisous à très
bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]